ça vous arrive de vous sentir un peu
parfois fatigué d'être dans un monde où
on est obligé de courir tout le temps
pour être le meilleur en faire des
meilleures écoles le meilleur le
milliard de travail du milliard dans ses
deux parents d'être comparé milanesi
comprendre d'être si bien le meilleur
citoyen celui qui va et elle est
toujours là tirer de se surpasser et et
ce sentiment d'être dans une course
permanente est parfait pas ses craintes
et finalement il n'y a pas tellement
d'autres possibilités pour toute façon
puisque d'une certaine manière les
ressources sont limitées il faut bien il
faut bien qu'ils avaient partie elle est
donc finalement une forme de justice
sociale de se dire qu'on est encore en
compétition les uns et les autres que
c'est comme ça quel que que notre nid
peut fonctionner sans être dans le chaos
eh bien je vais essayer aujourd'hui
vous faire explorer votre intérieur le
nombre de représentations celles qui
vous font dire que l'homme est
foncièrement mauvais fait des fraudes
sur internet et et une revoir
inversément présentation et vous parlez
en fait d'un monde où on traite on peut
articuler le désir de chacun d'être un
individu à part entière d'avoir sa
propre liberté son propre rythme et le
vivre ensemble et on peut l'articuler en
fait sous un mode coopératif donc comme
la nôtre la personne qui m'a introduite
moi j'y travaille ces questions qu'ils
ont ce talent dauphine dizaine d'années
au crédoc centre de recherche pour
l'étude des conditions licques et au
cours de mes recherches mais aussi au
cours de beaucoup de mon quotidien en
fait m'est apparu cette possibilité d'un
autre bout que je vais essayer de faire
exploser
alors vous allez me dévoue
à l'air sympathique ce monde n'était pas
du tout celui d'un planning aujourd'hui
on est évaluée en permanence toute la
journée en fait tu vas avoir des lay
donc on va mettre des postes demander si
finalement vous amis ont bien aimé ce
qu'on a mis sur les réseaux sociaux on
est même évaluer même sur le marché de
l'amour maintenant les applications de
rencontre est d'une certaine manière la
compétition elle s'est inspirée dans
tous les champs de notre vie y compris
ceux de la vie privée parfois même on
est même en compétition avec soi même
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir une forme de
on va compass regarder sur sur des
applications court plus vite que la
veille où si on a fait attention car le
nombre de pas dans la journée contre on
n'avait pas été fixée donc dans cet
objectif toujours de se surpasser les
voies réseaux
et au delà d'un principe de réalité il
ya aussi cette idée très présentes que
l'homme est foncièrement mauvais qu il
est narcissique l'homme où la femme qui
la narcissique il est égoïste qui me
porte qu'à lui même et qui là qu'il est
en fait gouverné par son propre intérêt
et cette idée en fait
qu'en fait je vous proposais de la de
faire un exercice de pensée
c'était pas parce que l'homme d'égoïste
les individualistes qu'on vit dans un
monde compétitif
mais ce que je vais vous proposer
d'imaginer aujourd'hui c'est que celle
inverse c'est parce que son nez dans la
monde qui est organisée sous un mode de
la compétition on est toutes les
pris dans fait donc dans ces chemins a
essayé de courir les uns plus vite que
les autres pour essayer d'obtenir le
meilleur emploi le meilleur logement le
meilleur amoureux brad était
alors vous allez me dire que j'ai une
vision un petit peu utopique de la vie
on dit aujourd'hui dans un langage
courant de lever un peu dans le monde
des bisounours
et donc je suis un peu dans un monde qui
a l'air très très désirable mais qui est
quand même assez peu raide et cette idée
en fait d'un monde d'un monde où l'homme
est profondément méchante narcissique où
il ne pense qu'à lui même en fait elle
elle date d'il ya 400 ans elle a été
très popularisé vous faites par un
écrivain qui s'appelle qui s'appelle
manville qu'un écrivain anglais un
philosophe qui a vu mettre en avant
l'idée que pour qu'une société
fonctionne bien il fallait que ce soit
organisé sous le mode de la compétition
ou en tout cas qu'il fallait laisser les
gens allaient à leur vie privée et que
c'est en laissant ses vitrines et qu'on
allait arriver à un bien public donc il
a écrit un livre qui s'appelle la fable
des abeilles et raconte donc l'histoire
d'une société des aveugles ou les
abeilles décide d'être honnête de bien
se comporter les unes avec les autres et
petit à petit en fait à force est
reconnaître ma la société penny pic il
ya plus de conflits donc il ya plus
besoin d'avocat il ya plus de riches
donc il ya plus besoin d'artistes pour
les divertir il ya plus de voleurs et de
long qui vont prôner donc il ya plus
besoin de policiers bref le monde en
fait safadi et il n'arrive plus à
progresser à se surpasser et de cette
femme en fait des rides et qu'il faut
laisser les gens allaient dans l'eure
l'eure plus sombre toutes nos pensées et
que globalement la société vraiment
profiter qu'on va s'enrichir à la fois
financièrement mais aussi en termes de
conditions de vie et c est cette idée
elle est reprise par un économiste qui
s'appelle adam smith en la
perfectionnant un petit peu en
expliquant que non seulement le fait de
vivre dans une société où on laisse les
uns et les autres suivre leur propre
chemin et on les laisse un peu courir
les uns contre les autres elle allait
elle est bonne pour la société mais en
plus même individuellement elle va
permettre à chacun de se surpasser elle
va permettre aussi de société qui va
être créative qui va être innovantes
donc cette idée d'une société où la
compétition c'est non seulement à un
moyen de créer la justice sociale mais
aussi un moyen de
qui va produire
du bien-être du progrès elle est très
présente dans nos esprits
elle est tellement présent qu'elle a
même débordé les champs philosophique ou
économiques pour aller vers les champs
de la justice sociale aujourd'hui ça
nous paraît finalement naturel que
l'état fasse en sorte que l'on puisse
tous courir dans cet immense compétition
scolaire est donc l'objectif de pouvoirs
publics c'est quasiment de d'aider les
gens pour qui
il est une égalité des chances qu'ils
puissent partir derrière la même ligne
de départ donc on va essayer de
s'échiner à compenser les handicaps des
uns et des autres sachant qu'on a tous
évidemment des difficultés certains
certains à prendre d'autres d'autres à
lire etc et des difficultés qui se
peuvent être physiques dvd parfois des
handicaps sociaux on peut venir le
milieu nos parents ne parlent pas le
français etc etc et donc
vont devoir essayer de mettre tout le
monde à vers cette première ligne de
départ pour créer la compétition la plus
juste possible et donc avoir un modèle
social qui nous permette de vivre
ensemble sans nous déchirer
alors cette vision en fait d'une somme
de bonheur individuel qui devrait
arriver au bonheur collectif allait
complètement démentie par les sciences
sociales dans une enquête du credoc qui
s'appelle en cas de conditions de vie et
aspirations
on mesure que d'un côté on à 73% de la
population qui nous disent qu'ils se
sentent intégrés personnellement dans la
société française et dans le même temps
on n'a que un quart de la population qui
considèrent qu'il vit dans une société
où il ya une cohésion sociale qui est
forte donc on voit bien au fait que la
somme des bonheurs collectifs la somme
des situations individuelles
contrairement à la fable la fable des
abeilles ou au regard d'un m16 le
conduit ben en fait un bonheur collectif
on peut tout à fait se sentir bien dans
ses baskets et avoir le sentiment que la
société part à vau l'eau et qu'il n'y a
pas en fait d'unité-vie le cohésion
une autre chose en fait que mon copain
qui est assez parlante quand on regarde
notre dans le monde on vit on voit d'un
cas quand même un petit peu de un petit
peu de ressentiment du ressentiment à la
fois du côté des personnes qui sont
plutôt les perdantes de la course
permanente donc là je vous ai mis des
images de gilet jaune mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres mouvements sociaux qui
sans arrêt à 10 et moi je n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres cette course pas parce que
je ne suis pas méritant pas parce que je
ne me lève pas tous le matin mais parce
que j'ai eu à l'état difficulté et on ne
m'a pas aidé dans ses difficultés et
donc d'un côté en fait de l'échiquier
social on a des longues qui ce qu'ici
non seulement sont les perdants de la
course mais en plus qui refusent encore
en tout cas qui n'ont pas envie d'être
responsable d'être perdant de la course
parce qu'évidemment personne n'a envie
de se dire que non seulement il a raté
mais qu'en plus c'est de sa faute est à
l'autre bout du spectre on a des
personnes qui sont on va dire les
gagnants de cette course qui ont des
professions valoriser qui gagnent bien
leur vie etc et qui sont proches de
l'épuisement qui travaillent comme des
fous qui ne savent plus où donner de la
tête qui ont dû passer des concours à
n'en plus finir qui sans arrêt sont
remis sur leurs compétences sont sont
questionnés et donc qui arrive presque à
l'épuisement et ont créé en fait d'une
certaine manière avec cette course une
forme de ressentiment permanent tout le
monde critique l'autre tout le monde
j'ai dit que l'autre a eu plus de chance
que lui ou bien qu'il a mérité sa place
et qu'il en a marre que tout le monde se
plaignent et au total on a donc une
société où finalement tout le monde
court mais pas vraiment après son
bonheur
et bien en fait je pense qu' il faudrait
qu'on efface un petit peu évoluer nos
représentations
cette idée que l'homme il est
foncièrement égoïste qui les ont qui ne
pense qu'à lui même c'est évidemment une
partie de la réalité
on a plusieurs fonctions nous de la même
manière que quand on est petit parfois
on a envie de taper le voisin parce
qu'il nous a piqué notre saut dans le
bac à sable
mais on a aussi d'autres éléments dans
notre dans notre for intérieur tous les
ans et les autres et on a des exemples
autour de nous tout le temps en fait qui
nous montrent que l'homme n'est pas que
égoïste alors je vais vous donner
quelques exemples un premier exemple
c'est pas tout simplement la parentalité
il ya quand même encore beaucoup de gens
qui font des enfants
quand vous faites un enfant
passait beaucoup de temps la nuit à ne
pas dormir vous passez beaucoup de temps
le soir vous demandez comment est ce que
vous allez faire pour en occuper est-ce
qu'ils sont heureux et nous fait bien
parce que vous avez suffisamment été
sévère ou pas assez sévères bref donner
beaucoup de vous même de votre argent de
votre temps de votre de votre votre
esprit pour essayer de faire en sorte
que ces petits êtres complètement nous
ne tenons le départ de vient de tenir
on peut se dire que c'est finalement
assez narcissique parce qu'on essaye
d'avoir des prolongements de soi je
pense que si un des parents dans la
salle vous savez tous que les enfants ne
sont pas du tout des problèmes et qu'ils
ont leur propre leur propre façon d'être
leur propre façon d'être et de vivre
dans le monde donc ça c'est un exemple
assez assez parlant il y en a 90 ans de
partir dans un autre domaine d'ô même
complètement différent on y va en fait
je suis sûr que dans la journée
aujourd'hui vous avez dû acheter des
choses en tout cas c'est possible qu'il
y ait un certain nombre dans la tap qui
a acheté les choses en fait acte d'achat
il repose quasi exclusivement sur la
confiance en autrui
vous donnez de l'argent avant de
recevoir la marchandise vous ne savez
pas si cette marchandise
vous ne savez pas si on va pas vous
arnaquer et inversement celui qui va
vendre en fait il va aussi peut-être
vous donner la marchandise avant de
recevoir l'argent alors bien sûr il ya
des fraudes il ya des arnaques on en a
parlé tout à l'heure mais finalement à
l'échelle des millions de transactions
on passe tous les uns et les autres la
proportion des malversations si je
soutiens est relativement faible on peut
prendre encore un autre exemple pas dans
le quotidien met dans des situations de
crise souvent quand on voit des films un
peu de formules on voit que les gens qui
s'entre déchirent qui sont prêts à tout
pour obtenir les ressources des autres
et en fait dans les vraies situations de
crise on se rend compte que les gens
coopèrent non seulement le couvert mais
il se met presque en danger pour les
autres par exemple pendant les attentats
du 13 novembre dans le bataclan les des
personnes se sont mis en danger
simplement pour tenir la main d'une
autre personne dans l'inconnu de
quelqu'un qu'il ne connaissait
absolument pas juste par humanité en
fait juste parce que au fond de nous on
a aussi quelque chose qui va vers vers
l'autre et qui a envie en fait
finalement de de partager et de coopérer
la difficulté en fait de notre monde
actuel qui nous fait ressentir cette
jeune par rapport à un manque de
cohésion sociale ce n'est pas
l'individualisme ans ce n'est pas le
fait de penser chacun tout le temps que
ce soit c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'individualisation c'est à dire le fait
qu'on a envie chacun d'entre nous a
envie d'avoir son propre chemin il a
envie de
le choisir un petit peu sa religion de
choisir son mode de vie de choisir la
manière dont ils donc ils ont il
s'habille ce qu'ils mangent avec kiel
vie etc etc et donc les anciens modes de
coopération qui était très institué la
religion la famille l'entreprise sont un
peu de charité est en fait sont des
modes de coopération qui aujourd'hui ont
de plus en plus de mal à à nous aider à
faire société
d'une certaine manière par exemple là je
vous montre un exemple cette
individualisation on la voit dans plein
de choses mais on la voit par exemple
dans le tatouage
auparavant le tatouage c'était une
marque les marques corporelles c'était
des marques collectives
circonciseurs les enfants parce que il
rentrait dans la communauté on mettait
une marque chez les indiens pour céder
un double pour pour par rapport au
mariage aujourd'hui le tatouage c'est le
symbole même de sa propre identité
personnelle on a dessiné son tatouage il
nous rappelle quelque chose d'unique il
nous permet d'être nous mêmes donc c'est
cette difficulté d'individus qui ont
envie d'être pleinement eux-mêmes qui
qui qui questionne en fait les modes de
coopération et aux vêtements mais n'a
une chercheuse qui s'appelle elinor
ostrom et qui propose un autre mode de
vivre ensemble que celui de la
compétition ou que celui de l'état de
l'état totalitaire si je puis dire qui
permettrait de réguler des hommes
l'artistique et les gaullistes et cette
chercheuse c'est la première femme prix
nobel d'économie est
la travailler en fait sur ce qu'elle
appelle les communs donc les communs
c'est l'idée qu'en fait on peut avoir
nouvelle manière de vivre ensemble une
nouvelle qui s'appuie sur des antiennes
qui existe depuis très longtemps on
pouvait avoir une ressource par exemple
une forêt où une ressource immatériels
comme par exemple wikipedia une
communauté de gens qui vont avoir envie
de s'en occuper qui vont qui vont ils
vont donner de leur temps ça peut être
des personnes des entreprises des
associations etc et surtout et surtout
des règles pour fonctionner parce que la
coopération en fait elle n'est pas plus
spontané que la concurrence pour mettre
en place la concurrence dans notre
société on a besoin d'autorités de la
concurrence on a besoin de gens qui vont
évaluer si on est meilleur à l'école pas
et que c'était pas tout un tas de règles
sont mises en place et la coopération
pour exister elle a aussi besoin de
règles donc les règles qui étaient un
petit peu traditionnelle par le passé
aujourd'hui sont questionnés et dans cet
espace des communs on peut imaginer de
retravailler ensemble mais en négociant
finalement les règles des uns avec les
autres alors ça peut vous paraître un
petit peu théorique mais en fait ça
existe déjà en france il ya 1800 tiers
lieux qui sont des espaces qui ont été
investis par des citoyens ou ou des
associations et/ou des entreprises etc
et qui sont gérés de cette manière là où
les règles sont négociés par exemple il
y en a à caen qui s'appelle le weed et
qui est dans un endroit qui était
totalement sinistré de beaux fourneaux
métallurgique dézinguer des personnes ce
sont cent sont emparés c'est devenu un
lieu qui fait du coworking qui a une
activité économique avec de
l'événementiel et qui fait aussi de
l'inclusion sociale avec avec des
manifestations artistiques et c'est
donc finalement ce que ce que je vous
propose en fait deux de faire
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire qu on peut
avoir un autre monde c'est possible par
contre ce n'est pas forcément facile sa
demande pour sa de changer beaucoup de
choses ça demande de changer un certain
nombre de valeurs de changer aussi
finalement tout ce qu'on va essayer
d'apprendre aux enfants la manière dont
on fonctionne par exemple sa demande
peut-être de sortir de l'évaluation
individuelle pour aller vers d
évaluation collective à l'école évaluer
des projets et savoir si des gens ont
réussi finalement arrivé à bon port
plutôt que sans arrêt leur demander si
leur dire ce qu'ils sont arrivés en
premier un deuxième un troisième ou un
quatrième dans classement de la classe
au travail aussi à côté d évaluation
individuelle masques une équipe projet
arrive à mener son projet et comment est
ce qu elle y est arrivée qui a été le
petit rouage qui a permis de tout
facilité qui peut être été invisible
dans l'évaluation individuelle lorsqu'il
a des compétences qui sont peut-être pas
très perfectionné mais qui sont à fait
essentiel au bon fonctionnement d'une
équipe
ça demande aussi de changer un petit peu
d'horizon au lieu d'aller vers un
horizon de la réussite individuelle de
la cape de la confiance en soi par
exemple sa demande d'enseigner plutôt
l'humilité le compromis la capacité à
écouter l'autre
donc sortir en fait une allemande une
culture qui est très verticale où on a
quelqu'un qui décide où c'est très
efficace mais par contre ce n'est pas du
tout collaboratif donc ça demande aussi
de ralentir sa demande d'accepter en
fait les décisions prennent du temps
qu'on se mettre tous d'accord pour qu'on
négocie que petit à petit on arrive à un
consensus avec un mode d dion mais que
nécessairement ça sera beaucoup moins
rapide que quelqu'un qui prend une
décision tout seul dans son bureau
et d'une certaine manière ça nous emmène
aussi vers un chemin qui nous fait
sortir un petit peu de ce monde de la
compétition dont l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est essentiellement d'avoir cette
compétition allait là pour essayer
d'avoir le plus beau logement d'avoir le
plus beau métier d'avoir de posséder des
choses parce que l'horizon qui est le
plus présent dans nos sociétés c'est la
société de consommation et dans un
univers coopératif la chance qu'on peut
avoir c'est que certes on sera on
produira peut-être un petit peu moins
mais par contre on n'existe pas et en
tant qu'individu chacun d'entre nous en
fait a besoin d'exister a besoin d'être
connue a besoin d'apporter sa pierre et
donc via un mode coopératif on a une
manière finalement d'articuler cette
liberté individuelle et le vivre
ensemble
finalement on passe un peu d'une liberté
négative c'est-à-dire ma liberté
s'arrête où commence celle des autres à
liberté positif qui est la liberté de
s'engager alors on pourrait de tâter cd
[Applaudissements]